le président ukrainien avant
d'intervenir était en visite surprise à
Carson ce lundi volody mirzelens qui a
voulu marquer les esprits en se rendant
dans la dernière ville reprise par les
forces ukrainiennes à l'armée russe dans
le sud du pays reprise de Kerson qui
marque selon lui le début de la fin de
la guerre et la ferme que les troupes de
Moscou ont détruit toutes les
infrastructures de la région avant de
partir entraînant des pénuries on fait
le point avec nos équipes en Ukraine et
notre envoyé spécial tallinunjan bonjour
Taline vous êtes dans la région de
mikolaïve hier vous étiez à Kerson pour
cette visite de volody mirzelenski
journée émouvante pour tous les
habitants de cette ville libérée
ah oui tout à fait l'atmosphère est
extrêmement émouvante à Carson il faut
le dire on s'attendait peut-être à ce
que les célébrations et diminué quelque
peu cela fait quand même quelques jours
que les forces russes sont sorties de la
ville et bien pas du tout les habitants
continuent de se réunir sur la place de
la Liberté pour chanter danser ils
enlacent les soldats qui sont accueillis
comme des héros on a même vu des enfants
leur demander de leur signer des
autographes sur leurs vêtements et hier
un autre de leur héros vous l'avez dit
c'est rendu à Carson et bien c'était
volody Meers zellenski qui a salué une
foule en liesse et je dois dire que nous
aussi journalistes on a reçu un accueil
très chaleureux la population était
véritablement contente de nous voir hier
en fait dans la journée de lundi c'était
le premier grand accès qui a été donné à
la presse à Carson on était plus d'une
centaine de journalistes sur place parce
que maintenant les entrées et sorties de
la ville sont toujours très très
contrôlées il est très difficile
d'obtenir des autorisations parce que
les forces ukrainiennes elles sont en ce
moment sur un immense travail de
sécurisation de la ville notamment avec
des travaux de déminage bonjour Taline
volody mirzelinski a accusé hier lors de
sa visite les Russes avoir détruit les
infrastructures les plus cruciales à
Carson c'est ce que vous avez pu
constater également
oui tout à fait malgré la joie qui
s'affiche sur les visages des habitants
de Carson et bien il manque de tout ils
n'ont toujours pas d'eau pas
d'électricité pas de connexion Internet
ni téléphonique parce que les
infrastructures essentielles elles ont
été en grande partie détruites par les
forces russes pendant les combats donc
en ce moment les autorités publiques
ukrainiennes elles mettent le turbo pour
essayer de réparer tout cela au plus
vite et tout cela en sachant aussi qu'on
continuait d'entendre en bruit de fond
des tirs d'artillerie et maintenant des
alentours mais la population n'y prête
absolument pas attention comme si elles
étaient complètement habituée ou bien
peut-être qu'elle est trop heureuse pour
ne serait-ce qui pensait en revanche
qu'on a pu observer aussi chez des gens
et bien c'est un profond traumatisme de
ces de ces 8 derniers mois d'occupations
russes il y a beaucoup de de personnes
qui qui que ce soit de soulagement
tristesse et bien elle n'arrivait pas à
finir leurs larmes et elles nous ont
confié à quel point l'ambiance était
terrifiante pendant ces 8 mois
d'occupation russe beaucoup de personnes
nous ont parlé de K2 de kidnapping de
torture les gens n'osaient pas sortir de
chez eux parce que c'était constamment
fouillé par les forces russes qui
fouillaient leur téléphone à la
recherche d'un quelconque message ou
photo en soutien à l'Ukraine donc voilà
la parole se libère ces derniers jours
et hier une femme m'a montré dans ses
mains elle m'a montré une dizaine de
jeux de clés ce sont les jeux de clés de
ses amis qui sont morts pendant ces 8
derniers mois et voilà donc c'est c'est
un sentiment très mitigé entre
soulagement et profonde traumatisme qui
qui qui
demeure chez les habitants de Carson
Carson libéré mais très meurtrie en tout
cas comme nous l'a confié notre
habitante et bien pour eux l'essentiel
c'est que maintenant Carson soit
ukrainienne le reste est désormais
derrière eux et Moscou qui continue de
considérer personne comme faisant partie
de la Russie merci beaucoup talilian on
voyait spécial de France 24 dans la
région de demicolaïve en Ukraine merci à
lucjrago et Wassim Dali qui sont avec
vous 9h09 ici à Paris Damien la suite du
journal